... (18 seconds pause)
from the level
Good evening to all.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Good evening.
Good evening, sir.
Hello?
Good evening.
Good evening, all. Good
evening.
That's
okay.
(silence)
Good evening, sir.
Hello. Hello.
Good evening. Good evening.
(waves hand) I think
I
can share my screen now. We can
..........................
So, uh,
the plan, uh, see, so far we have completed
the first level of understanding about this neural network.
We have understood
starting with a single perceptron, how we have came to the world
of this multi-layer perceptron network, as well as
then what is the feed forward connections, what we do
in the feed forward case, calculating the loss,
and then what is the role of back propagation.
And we have understood everything by
the three aspects in the sense conceptual understanding we have tried to
develop. We also have seen the mathematics behind it that
what exactly goes inside the network when we do the
feed forward and, uh, uh, back
propagation. And the third way what we have seen to
understand these, these, uh, topics are from the hands-on.
So we have also seen everything working in the PyTorch.
So only, only, only part is now you have
to put your effort and do some, um, uh,
hands-on by yourself. And I guess then these concept- concepts will be quite
clear to all of you. And you should be coming with the
dots if you have any, uh, if you have any in between, anytime you can ask
us. Uh, that is, that is absolutely fine.
So, uh, uh, be-before we start this, uh, this is
the fourth week what we are in right now and, uh, in the initial plan we
had said that we will conduct the quiz at the end
of the fourth week.
So, uh, uh, so we can either conduct on the coming
Saturday or we can go for next Monday.
Uh, yeah, that is what we can do.
Let us, let us listen to them.
Yes, yes.
The next Monday?
(laughs)
(laughs) Okay.
Uh...
So no problem, no problem. We'll do it on next Monday.
Fine.
Yeah, right.
So that was one part. So, uh, I'll also
ask my TAs to make this announcement because others may not have
joined. They should not come with a surprise next day, sir, when it was announced.
No. (laughs) So, .......................... Are you there?
I don't know. Uh, some- one of you can please make this announcement in the
LMS.
Okay, sir.
Sir, uh, yes, sir, I am here only.
Yeah. Thank you.
Yes, sir.
Hey.
So-
Can you make the announcement now itself?
(laughs)
So what will be the format, sir? Like, um...
It will be quiz. Quiz. I mean, in the sense MCQ
and coming with the LMS itself. So it will be integrated in the
LMS. So around, uh, fif- 30 minutes quiz,
that is what it will be, 15 to 20 questions.
Yeah. One mark each.
Okay.
The coming Monday is at 7:45 only,
right?
Coming Monday?
If it is on weekdays, then it is on 7:45 Monday, right?
Right, right. Next Monday. Today is Monday, right? Next Monday, 7:45.
So we can start, uh, so that day, yeah, a little later,
maybe around 8:00 we'll start. By the time all of you will join and
then, uh, we can have...
Yes.
So, uh, will it have the mathematical equation type, means, problematic will
be there?
Yes, yes. It can be anything now whatever we have covered, but it will be MCQ
type.
Okay. It may have some PyTorch, uh, clu- code
snippet also, which you may have to understand and
comprehend. May have conceptual questions or it may have a
little bit of, uh, numerical based questions also where you
may have to calculate the, how the neuron works, what is the output of
it or something like that. So, but whatever we have covered, we'll ask
only from that. So whatever we will be
covering, uh, this week, that will also goes
there.
Okay?Till
today or till Saturday, sir? Till, till Saturday. Okay.
Nothing. Yes, yes.
Okay. all right. So,
uh,
that was one, one thing which I wanted to discuss.
Sir, one quick check, sir.
Hmm. Hmm.
Venugopal here. So will it include python snippets also or only...
Yes. Yes. It may... It, it may include that also because we
are spending, I mean, good time to understand the
PyTorch. So some... One or two questions, but in the form of MCQ itself,
welcome.
Thank you, sir. My request.
Yes.
Yep. Okay.
So, uh, as, as I said that we have understood at least the first level
of, of, of this neural network working, uh, that how exactly it
works and all. Now we'll try to go little
deeper. Okay. Uh, we'll try to understand,
uh, uh, means, uh, that how
exactly the many other, other,
uh, functionality which is associated with this neural networks are, uh, are
being computed. What is the concept behind it and where and all they
are being used. So maybe few classes from now onwards will go
on little advanced concepts
and whatever we are learning now for ANN,
most of the concept is going to be true, uh, for
whatever higher or deeper network we learn in the coming, coming classes
like, uh, CNN, RNN, LSTM. Okay? There we
may not be able to explain everything in detail, but
the, the concept will remain same.
And, uh, the cal- uh, the way it, it, it, it happens here, most of the things
will remain same. Okay. So from now
onwards, we'll try to go into little deeper into the network and understand the
different aspects of the artificial neural network.
So today what I have planned, uh, that, uh,
few, few things, uh,
what I will cover will be... I'll quickly recap the back propagation and we'll
try to understand why back propagation works,
which I have explained at the first level, but I'll
quickly, uh, cover that part also.
And then we'll cover the stochastic batch and
mini-batch gradient descent. Although we have covered this one in
the linear regression in the first course
MLP, but here also we'll, we'll try to cover because it,
it is having the same concept. So you will quickly understand this part as
well. Now we'll try to spend some time to understand the vanishing
gradient problem of ANN, which is very important to understand,
right? And we'll also see the... What are the different ways
we have for handling this vanishing gradient problem with some examples and
visuals we'll try to understand that part.
So this... We are going to cover...
We'll see how much we are, uh, able to cover today.
And then a few more classes will be required with the...
To cover few more things. Like I, I...
Although I had planned to cover, uh, the PyTorch, few more modules are
left. For example, we have covered so far the autograd, but we are
left with this, uh, NN module, neural
network module, which will help us to build the neural network
layers. Okay? So that we are going...
Uh, we have to cover, which we are not covering today, but next class I will try to
cover and optimize it. That is another concept very important in neural
network training. So that is also...
We have one module in the PyTorch also.
So, so few things you see that, and it may take another, I think, three to four
classes, including the quiz I guess to cover the advanced level,
advanced topics in the ANN. Once we'll have complete understanding
of these things, then we can proceed with the deeper networks like CNN,
RNN or LSTM. So that's the plan what we have.
Okay.
Fine. So let us start.
Will it be as per schedule, Sureel? Or it will exceed?
It is exceeding, sir, a little bit.
Uh, we said that by fourth week we'll start, uh, CNN.
Mm-hmm.
So maybe this week we are not starting it. We'll start next week.
Okay. Yes. Yeah. Fine, fine. Thank you.
Okay.
So, uh, quickly, uh, the back propagation,
uh,
what we have already covered in the previous classes.
So we had taken one example of this type of
network where we had the two inputs, two hidden neurons and one output
neurons,
right? Then this slide, uh, we understood how
to... How do we do the feed forward...
Uh, feed forward propagation where we calculate the
prediction at the output layer and with that we also calculate the error or
we can say loss. So that, that was the feed forward.
So at every neuron we do this weighted sum plus bias that, that
part and followed by the activation function.
And activation function which we used here was the ReLU activation function, if you
can recall. Okay. And then we calculated the prediction as Y
hat, and we then calculated the error as
Y hat minus Y squared. So a squared error we calculated.
So that was the feed f- uh, forward in the neural network.
And then the next part was to do the back propagation.
And while doing the back propagation, the first thing what we learned was that we
need to calculate the gradient, okay?
And gradient will be calculated in the chain rule fashion
because the loss is only available at the output
layer. The loss is not available in the hidden layers.
So we need to back propagate the loss and we have used the chain rule for
that one to calculate the partial derivative with respect to a particular parameter
in the earlier layers. So here we...
As you can recall, we calculated the partial derivative of loss with respect to
each parameter-Okay. And then finally, we
updated these para- nine parameters, if you can see here, we have in this
particular network, and we updated all these parameter using this
update rule.
Okay. So we also, uh, understood the
concept of, uh, learning rate there, which we are going to see today as well
again. But learning rate was
helping us to control this, um, this gradient
size, which in this particular example came very big.
For example, you see that gradient is like 97, 26, 14
point something. It was even 1413.12,
right? So the gradients were so big.
Now if you'll go ahead with this gradient and update the, uh, update
the parameter, there will be a huge change in the parameter because
the initial parameter value is, say, 1.2, 0.8 and you're
subtracting or adding the value like 1413.
So from 1.2 you are going all the way up to 1413.
So there is a huge change and we don't want, we don't want such a
huge change at the time of training our, uh,
neural network, right? And that is why this learning rate has helped us
to, uh, control that, uh, uh, this, this, um,
um, you can say that very, very high...
large value of the gradient and, and that's how we have done a gradual
change, right? So, uh, learning rate has a significant
role in this particular update rule. That is what we had seen.
Now today we will see that, that how the learning rate, uh, impacts and what are
the different cases of that l- learning rate once again with the
figures. So we... This was the back
propagation. We updated all the parameter and that the...
then with the updated values of these parameter, again, we did
the forward propagation and then what we did, so i- this, this
slide was showing the before update of the parameter, the loss was
54.1696 and after updating all these
parameters, the loss was 4.005890.
So there was a significant drop in the loss and hence
we can say that by updating these parameters using back
propagation has, has, uh, uh, has reduced the
loss and our network has learned,
uh, the, the relations between the, uh, you can say input/output
in a better way. Okay? So this was just one parameter and with one input.
This was the change which we had seen
earlier. Now the question is,
uh, w- we will answer some of the questions now that why this back
propagation worked, right? And,
uh, uh, what was the... Uh, w- what,
what happened such that if we have changed these parameters, th- our loss was
decreased and, uh, how do we understood that, okay,
uh, whether, uh, uh, network has,
uh, d- done it better or not and all those answers.
That is what we have to understood.
So we have to n- now what we need to discuss is what are the
intuition behind this back propagation?
We understood that it is working in terms of the numbers, but now let
us go into the detail of it and let us see what each part of
that back propagation is doing in order to, uh, in order to,
um, uh, reduce that loss. Okay? So that is what we are
going to see next. And to understand that
part, the first thing which I w- I, I am bringing here is that
loss as a function of all trainable
parameters. Okay? Uh, so far what we have seen that
loss is being calculated by this, uh, equation
Y s- -Y hat square, which is a squared error
and then Y hat is this value, this equation, that
V1H1V2S2 and V3, if you can recall here.
So Y hat is being calcu- Y hat is depending on five, uh,
factors. Out of that, H1S2 is the,
um, input from the, um, uh, hidden layer and
then V1, V2 and V3 are my parameters, right?
So this Y hat is depending on these three parameters.
So straightaway you can see that loss depends on Y hat and Y hat is
depending on these three. That we have understood earlier also.
But what change, what I'm t- trying to bring now is that I say
that w- this, this Y hat is a
function of all the parameters what we have in the
network, all the parameters which we have in the network, and that is
why we were, uh, calculating the partial
derivative of loss with respect to each of
these parameter because w- uh, because my loss
is now depending on Y hat and Y hat is depending on each of these
parameter, like nine parameters we have in this network.
So if I'll change any of these parameters, it will impact
on my loss. Now, that was the intuition behind changing each and every
parameters. Now to understand that one, first of all, we need to understand
how this Y hat is depending on all the parameters, right?
Uh, we can see here Y hat is depending on B3 because B3, B3 is
directly connected with this Y hat.
Y hat is also depending on Y... V1 or V2 because these two are
But how Y hat is depending on W11 or W12, W21,
W22, B1 and B2? Because they are not directly connected with that
network. Okay? So this particular slide
is about that and you can see this one.
If we will... if you will unfold this Y hat,
okay? And you will write the Y hat as a nested
function,
then... Uh, w- it's a, it's a, it's a, uh, nested function obviously, but
when you will unfold this Y hat, you will end up with all the parameter
which is a part of, which is a part of this Y hat.
For example, Y hat
is directly w- depending on this equation,
V1H1V2S2andV3. Fine? And
this H1, H1 we got as a
ReLu of Z1.Means from the first neuron in the hidden
layer, we got Z1 as a weighted sum plus bias and when we pass
that weighted sum plus bias through the activation function ReLu, we got
H1. And similarly for H2 also, we calculated
Z2, passed it through the activation function ReLu, we got
H2. Now if you see how this Z1,
uh, eh, have been calculated, it is W11 X1 W12
X2 plus V1 and Z2 is being calculated by W21 X1 W22
X2 B2. Okay, now these are all the values for,
uh, equations for these, these, uh, variables. You can say that.
So now what I'm doing is I'm just substituting these value in place of
this... In, in this loss or in place of this Y
hat. So let me, uh, uh, say that this
equation I'm expanding first of all.
So here Y hat V1 and in place of H1,
I'm first writing this ReLu.
So you can see here ReLu, right? And, uh,
um, you can see a ReLu and then... One second.
Let me take some, uh,
pointer. Uh, so let
me take
this.
Uh, true. Okay, so this one. Uh, first of all, I'm
taking this ReLu, okay? And then, uh, here
after ReLu, inside the ReLu we have this Z1.
And what is Z1? Z1 is this W11 X1 W12 X2 and
V1. So ins- in place of this, uh, Z1, I'm writing this whole
equation. So V1 H1, here we have
H1 and this H1 is written completely as ReLu of W11
X1 W12 X2 and V1. Now this part, this
part in the equation V2 into H2. So V2 is written as it is
here and H2 is written as ReLu into W21
X1 W22 X2 V2.
Okay? And V3 is as it is. Now you can see that, right?
My loss, loss is Y minus Y hat, and Y
hat is a function of all the parameters what we have in
the network. You can see this. And that's why I said loss as a function
of all trainable parameters in the network,
okay? And that was the reason why we were updating
each and every parameter because, uh,
uh, i- if you can recall, uh,
if you can recall... Uh, one
second. Take some
other... No, this one. Let
me see this. Okay, so if you can recall
this particular plot which we had seen earlier also where we
had, uh, this, uh, um, eh, on the X axis we
were having the parameters. We had a parameter is AW11,
W11, okay? And on the Y axis we have a
loss. So what we said that if I change one
unit in W11, how much change it brings in the loss?
That itself is known as partial derivative or gradient,
okay? Now my loss is depending on each and every parameters in the
network. So what we are trying to do in the back propagation, we are trying
to see if I change one unit
or... in that particular parameter like W11, W12, B1,
B2, whatever is the parameter, how much change it is bringing in
the loss. Because as X will change, Y will change
and it depends on what is the slope, what is the gradient, and that,
that change, that much change we want to bring, okay?
In the next iteration when we will feed the next input and to see that, okay,
by changing that much, uh, i- in this particular
parameter, uh, then whether it is reducing my loss or i- uh,
increasing my loss or whatever it is.
Okay, so that was the intuition behind it, that why we were
changing, why we did not, uh, um, stopped
only at the output layer because my, uh, because
my... One second.
Because my ultimate Y hat was depending on V1, V2, V3.
But no, it is not the case, although it looks like, but then W11 and
W12 and all other parameters are also connected with the Y
hat in the nested fashion. Hence, we decided to change each of
these parameters. Okay, I think this, this, this is clear.
That, that's why, uh, we, we go ahead and change all those
parameters. Okay, now the point is concept of
gradient. So once we decide that, okay, each and
every parameter we need to update, we have an update
rule. And in the update rule, we have seen that, right?
Here again, that we have this part which is called a gradient.
So this gradient has a significant, uh, you can say,
uh, contr- uh, say in this particular equation that
whatever is this, uh, gradient, based on that, my
update will happen for that particular parameter.
So h- so the point is, uh, I have already although told
that Y gradient, the concept of gradient, so
ultimate goal is that we need to minimize the loss and the gradient says
that rate of change of loss with respect to a particular parameter.
Now we understood that my loss depends on all the parameters.
Whatever is the connection in the fully connected network, your loss depends on all
the parameters and hence we decide to, uh, change those
parameter, and for that one, we need the gradient because we don't know how much to
change. And that's where this gradient will help us in or-
until that, okay, in order to go, uh, go to the minima, okay,
this much change you, you should bet, uh, you, you should
do at this particular iteration. Okay?
So that's why, uh, the gradient is required.
So the gradient value, if you see that, uh, that
gradient, if it is greater than zero gradient, what we don't
want for the gradient is that we don't want gradient value to be
zero, right? We don't want gradient to be zero. Why?
Because if suppose this is zero, in this equation if the del L by del
theta is zero, what will happen? This whole term is zero....
if this whole term is zero, then theta is theta.
That means that my parameter is not changing.
If my parameter is not changing, there won't be any change in the loss
also, right? But we are, we ultimately, the goal is
to reduce the loss, so we need the change in this
theta and it depends on the second, the second
part of this equation, uh, this, this gradient.
So I don't want either my learning rate or
my, uh, gradient to be zero. I don't want this part to be zero.
So now I'm left with, uh, two choices.
Either this, this particular, uh, del L by del theta will be
greater than zero or it will be less than zero.
So when this del L by del theta, suppose when you are calculating the
gradient and it is coming greater than zero, so what will happen?
Eh, what does it mean? It means that
your increase in theta will increase the loss.
Theta represent here any parameter like W, I, J, V, K or
BL. So, it is representing that if you will increase that
particular parameter value, your loss will ongo- uh, your loss
will also increase. Okay?
Hence, we don't want to go in that direction.
We'll go into the opposite direction of it, opposite direction of
my, uh, gradient. Okay? Now the second
one is, it may happen that your, this, uh, gradient is less than
zero. Okay? That means that if you'll
increase this theta, your loss will
decrease. If you'll increase the theta or parameter
value, your loss will decrease. Fine?
So, uh, what happens in both the cases, we are
moving downward. Now h- I'll show you how. Okay?
I'll show you how. So let us see this particular curve.
You have seen it earlier, I know that, in the previous course.
We have discussed about it but then still, just to recall all those things.
Now we have talked about this, uh, convex curve,
right? And this is the curve for a loss, loss
function, okay? And I want my loss to be minimum,
minimum v- somewhere here, say that this, this is the value where it is minimum
in this particular curve. So now what I'm trying to say
is, here it is minimum, that means that this point is zero
because the loss is zero, uh, loss is minimum at the zero, so this is
zero. This side it is less than zero and this side
it is more than zero, okay? Uh, one
second, let me just
take the... Now, so here it is
zero, okay? And this side it is increasing
greater than zero and this side it is less than zero.
Now what I'm trying to say is when you calculate this, this
part, del L by del theta, it may happen that this value is
positive, this value is positive.
That means that, it says that if you increase the theta or
wherev- wherever is the theta, so if this is positive, this mean that you are this
side, th- this particular slope, okay? What you are seeing here.
If this value is negative, that means that you are this side.
And what it's, uh, what is the intuition behind it is, that if you will increase
the theta, your loss will increase, isn't it?
This curve is going up. Fine? So if theta will increase, corresponding
Y value will increase. Now if, if, if the slope is
like that in this direction, if the theta will increase, loss will
decrease because slope is going downward.
But whatever is the case, you see this, the beauty of this particular algorithm,
whatever is the case, you are going downward.
So that is what call we are taking here.
Whether, uh, your slope is here this side or your slope is here
this side, doesn't matter. You are going towards the global
minimum. Okay? And that is what
this particular part tells us in this particular loss o- in
this particular, uh, update rule.
Because this value will, will be m- it may be positive.
If it is positive, this what will happen?
You will, theta minus something you will do.
Okay? Theta minus something you will do. Then what does it mean?
Suppose theta is equal to one. Suppose, okay?
And this part is positive, say that it, it has come as, uh,
0.8, okay? This is 0.8. Say that my,
uh, learning rate is equal to one. So what you will do in this case?
1 minus 0.8 is equal to zero point- uh, 1 minus
0.8 is 0.2. That means that suppose this point was one,
you have come to this particular point, means you are going towards this
direction, towards this minimum.
Now suppose this value is positive, sorry, negative, okay?
Del L by del theta is, uh, uh, negative, that means that what
will happen? Negative, negative becomes positive.
This equation becomes positive and now whatever is the theta, you will
add into it. So this t- this side, you are
decreasing the theta and this side you will increase the theta.
That is how this equation works for both the side of this particular
curve. So the takeaway is
you have to go into the opposite direction of the gradient.
If the gradient is here, means upward,
increasing, you have to go downward because
here, here you have the lo- uh, global minimum.
If your, uh, slope is downward, means decreasing,
okay? Uh, then, then also you have to go downward.
In both the cases, you have to go downward only.
So this side also and this side also we are going downward and hence you are
achieving here. And that's why this equation, one equation works in both
the cases. So you see that this particular part of the equation is
acting like a sign,
sign that okay, whether I am going to increase
my theta or parameter value or decrease my theta value,
positive or negative, that is what this particular part of the
equation, this gradient is telling us.
So gradient tells the slope of the loss curve at the current parameter
value. Gradient says how steeply the loss
is increasing or decreasing, that we have already seen, uh, talked.
If the gradient is positive like this side here......
the curve is sloping upward. If the gradient moves opposite,
gradient, uh, descent moves opposite, the slope, uh, the slope is
downhill. That is the min- at the minimum, slope is equal to zero, the flat point
means here, okay? The slope is fla-flat, uh, flat point.
This is what we want to achieve ultimately. Okay?
So... Clear. So, I
guess it, it, it has given you more clarity that, okay, why this update rule?
What is the significance here of the gradient, okay, and how this gradient
works for both the side of this curve.
And this is called convex curve, right?
Which, uh, which, um, we, uh, uh...
And in the convex curve, the good part is you have only one minima and that i- that
happens to be the global minima and then this equation help us, or this
gradient help us to go in the direction of that global
minima.
Okay, so this is the concept of gradient and, uh, minima.
Uh, it is related with the minima. Okay, so
now, uh, the, uh, this is for two dimension, how this
loss is changing with one parameter, right?
Suppose you have just one parameter here, W_11. Okay?
But now in our network we have seen we have nine parameters. Okay?
We have nine parameters. That means that for every parameter, we are doing this
calculation. Means, for every parameter, we are calculating this gradient or
slope, and we are deciding that, okay, in which direction we have to
go to achieve the global minima. So, here the
example of the 3D, okay, because 9D I can't show you.
So but in, 'till 3D we can visualize it.
For example, here you can see that, that... See this.
This is theta_1, say that this is W_11.
This is theta_2, so that this is W_12. These two are the parama-...
And this is the loss. This is, this, uh, axis is the loss.
So, my gradient is minimum here because this
is the zero. This is, uh, you can say this is the,
uh, loss-loss is zero. Oh, okay? So,
maybe this is the point, suppose we have, so what we have to do is,
it may happen that your theta value you will initialize somewhere here in this side
or this side. Okay? Any, any random value y- you don't want to initialize it with
zero, so you will be somewhere this side or this side.
Similarly, theta_2 you will initialize this side or this side and any side of the
zero. But the ultimate job is to reach, suppose
here, then what will happen? You have to, um, y- you have to
see that, okay, what is the slope with respect to...
Uh, so w-one more thing is, uh, what you have to do is whenever
you calculate a gradient, okay, gradient, gradient of that, uh,
with respect to theta, you have to equate it with zero.
Now, that is the place where you will get the minima for,
with, for that particular parameter. So what you will do?
Wah-partial derivative of loss with respect to theta_1 is equal to zero you will
do. Partial derivative of loss with respect to theta_2 is equal to zero you will do
and that's how you will, uh, get the value of theta_1, theta_2 and then you can
decide that, okay, what is the point where the global minima and in that direction
you will start going. So this is, uh, same thing what
we have seen for one para- one, uh, you can say that,
uh, parameter. Now this is for the two parameter and
similarly we can extend it for nine parameters also and
hence it works in the multi dime-...
Uh, um-um-uh, for every dimension it calculates the gradient and then it
trains all, uh, it calculates all those gradients by equating that value to the
zero and then it finds, okay, where is the global
minima.
Fine? So, uh, this is what is the concept of the
gradient. Now there is one more, one more part
in this particular equation is about the learning rate, okay?
So learning rate as you know, this one also we have
talked in the previous, uh, uh, class, previous course,
that, uh, how does this learning rate, uh, uh,
uh, how-how d- how does it behave? Suppose we take the learning rate
very small, then what happens? Suppose we take this learning rate very large,
then what will happen and moderate, then what will happen.
So you can see here, uh, the, uh, in the first case
when you take the learning rate very small, suppose you are at this side of the
curve, you can be any side. Here I'm showing for the right side.
Then what will happen? Because the learning rate, this value is very small, you
will slowly go in the direction of the global minima.
If it is very big, like third case right here, then it may
happen that you started from here and you jump to the other side
because the learning rate was very big.
You had to decrease this theta but then you have decreed it with a
significant amount. So you see this? This equation you have to always remember.
So either this part, this gradient or this learning
rate, uh, it-it, uh, if-if these two
values are very big or very small, it will impact on this overall
equation. That what will be the next value of the theta?
It depends on both of these, uh, both of these, uh,
uh, q-quantity, right? Learning rates and, uh, g-gradient
both. If you r-can recall the, in our earlier
case where, uh, we were getting this, uh, gradient as
very big. So we take a learning rate very
small. Okay? If we would have taken learning rate one also,
what would have happened? We would have seen the significant change in my
parameter. That is what we discussed, okay? You can see that.
1,4, 1,3, 97, 26, such a big gradient we were
getting. So if we would have taken say V_1, say that
1.2 minus 97.152. It's a huge change
around 95. Okay? Forget about the sign but 95 is
the change magni- in the magnitude in the V_1 with a hu-huge
change and you're, you will see that in such cases where the
gradients or you can say that this learning rate, one, one of these is
very big, you will see this kind of behavior of,
uh, the loss with respect to that particular parameter or even in the higher
dimension you can see that. So you are not converging.
Instead you are jumping to one another side of this particular curve.And
it may happen that you... By, uh, because, uh, you
will go here, there and it may happen that you will explode and you will go out of
this particular space itself. Okay?
That, that is another problem called exploding gradient problem, which I'll talk
later. But this is what may happen.
This is, this is what may happen with if you will take this learning rate value
very big. So, the good practice is to take this as
moderate. This, uh, as moderate. U- usually the moderate when I say
it is like 0.01, okay? Or 0.1.
So, this is what is the range, I have seen that but that moderate
has also its own meaning, it d- it's, uh...
So, this is a hyper parameter which is not fixed.
It is also tunable, it is also learnable along with the
weights, biases and what gradient you are getting.
This parameter also you learn with the, with the training of the neural network.
So, it is not fixed. Fine?
So, these are the three cases, learning rate and this also
impacts on your, uh, in your, uh, uh, you can say that
the back propagation in this update rule. Fine?
So, it decide how, how, how you are... How...
Whether you're converging, not converging, how fast you're converging
and how slow you will converge. This e- uh, this eta learning ra- rate
has the significant, uh, uh, say in that
one. Fine? So, here you can read this
thing. So, the point is, what is convergence? Okay.
Uh, because we have been talking about what is, uh, the convergence, convergence
and so on in all the cases. But what is the meaning of convergence?
So, the convergence refers to a point in training where
updates to the parameter become very small. Fine?
So the point is, okay, if I will plot, I'll plot...
I can understand always but if we plot also how, where do we understand,
okay, we are converging? Or if you see our loss values, how do we
understand we are converging? So this is the, um, this is the point what
we have to observe. It refers to a point in training where
updates to, updates to the parameter becomes very small, almost
negligible. Then you can say that my
algorithm or my network has converged.
Okay. Uh, updates to the parameter becomes very small because the loss
function is no longer decreasing significantly.
If loss will, uh, is not changing, uh, that means that,
uh, your parameters are conve- have converged.
That is the maximum those parameters can do with the given set of the input
and output. Fine? So, this
is the, uh, just a, uh, representation of that, that you have a
loss on the Y-axis. So, how the loss i- is decreasing?
You can say that after certain point if you see that it is almost
constant. It is almost constant. That means that your,
your network has, uh, converged and then,
um, the, there is no further update in the parameter.
So, you can stop training. And if you feel that, okay, this is not
the, um, uh, you can, eh, still it is very far from
zero, or, uh, then you have to see if there's some other ways.
Means, the number of iteration will not help in such a case.
Fine? So, when the gradients or loss change fall below the threshold,
we say that training has converged. That is also another way of understanding that.
The zero you will never achieve but suppose you are achieving something near the
0.5, 0.4, you can say that it has
converged. Okay.
So, the meaning is network has learned parameter close to a minimum, further
update produced almost no improvement.
So, that is the meaning of the convergence.
Okay, so, a- a- any queries so far? Then I'll go to the next part for the
stochastic batch and mini-batch.
Uh, sir, uh, you brought out very clearly about the convex, uh, thing and how we
are using this back provocation and we're following the global minimizer.
Sir, like, in case if, suppose if I have a data set where I'm getting a con-
uh, concave function. So at that time the curve will be i- inverted
U kind of thing. So at that point of terms instead of taking a logs,
uh, can I go for accuracy and I can evaluate for the maximization of
accuracy? Can I use that inference?
Because when we're having this global minimum, you're going for loss to minimize.
So, if we go for a concave function, then my...
It'll be for maximization. So at that time, I can change the in- thing
to accuracy, uh, as my goal and I can go for
maximization of accuracy. So that can be used or I have to convert this
again to convex and go for, uh, this?
See, I'll tell you. Uh, see, uh, usually, usually
we... Uh, our, our neural networks or any kind of
algorithm, uh, we... The loss function is the
ultimate objective. We have to always minimize the loss function.
Right? And this, this accuracy what you are talking-
Sir.
... it is d- direct... It is... It depends on the loss.
If your loss will decrease, accuracy will increase.
So, if you will plot the accuracy plot, it will go into the other way.
See, because the loss-
Yes,
sir. ... is increasing, that means that accuracy has to
Yeah. But the good practice is this, what- what- uh, yeah.
Yes. So in case if I have a concave, then how to convert into convex,
sir?
No, I mean, see, the ultimate goal of learning is what we
want that we have to minimize this loss.
Minimize the loss, yes.
Okay? So that is the goal which we have set.
If you have set this goal and then you have
to... You- you will always fall- fall into this particular
situation. Then it-
Yes.
... will not be a situation we have to convert from that concave to convex
and those things will not come into the picture, right?
Suppose you are not choosing the correct loss function, that is a separate case,
non-convex function you will get where you may have the multiple, uh, you can
say that, uh, uh, minima and you will have one global minima,
many local minima, and there is a chance to stuck into the local
minima. So there is a separate part for that which we'll see when
we'll go further. Okay? There are some other- other ways of
coming if you are not, uh, uh, uh, choosing the correct loss
function and if there is a multiple minima in your loss function.
So we'll see that in the, in the later classes.
Okay, sir.
Uh, sir, quick clarification for me.
Yes.
In the 3D graph that you have shown, uh, loss versus
parameter. Yeah, this one, this one.
Uh, for global minima, all the theta values, I mean, all
parameters must be, uh, zero.
Correct.
I mean to say when theta one is zero, is there a chance that theta
two must have other value?
No, no, you have to equate it at... Equate it at theta two, so
what I say that a minimum occurs when
gradient in every dimension is zero.
Okay, well, all the parameters must be zero. Okay.
So that is what we have to... Once you calculate this, equate it with a zero
and then see that what is the theta value you can extract from there and
then esti- uh, that is the point where it is going to
be minima. Yes, that is the point where it is going to be minima.
So it must be zero. That's why this slide comes.
Yes. So, sir, another small
query. Uh, you said, uh,
the gradients affect the learning rate of the model.
Yeah.
Uh, is always a higher learning rate is preferred
or no, it's
not? No, I say neither high nor small. None of...
Usually the moderate is the one which- which is preferred,
but that also comes with the situation in the sense that
what set of inputs you have-
Okay.
... what set of weights you are initialized with, that also depends on the
learning rate value.
For example, I have given this example.
This learning rate is never preferable, one into 10-
Okay.
... to the power of minus four. It is very small learning rate.
Very small. Okay.
But I have chosen it because my gradient was going very
high. So why gradient was going high?
That also we learned, right? Because my-
Yes.
... dia- like range for the inputs, x1 is 80 and x2
is eight, both range are for 10, the range is
different. Okay? So that's why...
So the good practice is always normalize your input, first of
all-
Okay. ... before passing to the neural network.
Neural
As well as choose the weights-
Weights.
... also in a particular, uh, with a particular distribution so that it-
it will also will be in a particular range.
In such cases, in such case when you are following
then learning rate is always moderate value which is- which is
This is preferred. Okay.
The preferred. Yeah.
Sir, I have one question.
Yes, please.
Yes.
So sir, uh, I know it can be a repetition but I just wanted to
clarify. Sir, why can't we just only rely on the
gradient? Like what, why do we always need a learning rate in
our case?
I- I think I've given you a very good example just now.
Suppose I don't use this learning rate, I can fix it as
one. Okay. Learning rate one means I'm not using this learning rate-
Yes.
... isn't it?
I'm completely relying on my gradient. Then what will happen?
This is what you can see. What would have happened that 1.2 this 10 to the
power of four will be one instead of this 10 to the minus four and
then 1.2 minus 97.152. So
V1 next value would be around 95
or minus 90 whatever you say. So from 1.2 we are changing it
to 95 and then you will see this kind of problem because learning
rate is changing... I mean sorry, this uh, uh, the parameter is
changing so say that you are somewhere here, uh, the loss
function here you can say that my parameter value is 1.2
somewhere here, I'm changing into 95 going very...
Somewhere
in the very right side. So
there is a huge change in this theta, there is huge change in this theta
either this side or this side doesn't matter but if there is a huge change in this
theta my- my gradient is here, min- minima is here
I want to just come here that is the ultimate goal I have fixed but I'll...
If I'll do huge change what will happen either- either I will go in this direction
or this direction if I'm going in this direction also I'll end up somewhere here
because 90... Minus 95 is here and which is very far from my,
uh, global minima and that is why I don't want
this such a big change in the theta because theta is in x axis you
imagine the theta is in x axis so you- if you want to
come here from here you don't want very huge change
okay so this learning rate somehow controls that, that what would be
your step size or what will be your step towards
achieving this minima. Okay ultimately you have to reach so whether
you go with the 60 kilometer per hour or 10 kilometer per hour or
200 kilometer per hour now that is what is being controlled by this
learning rate and eventually it will help you to converge here yeah
so if you don't use that one-
Got it sir.
... then you know the direction that okay from here I have to go there but then you
will not stop because your speed is too high step size is too-
too high so you will jump this side...Okay? Yeah.
Okay, sir, thank you.
So it may even lead to, uh, unstable convergence also.
So you will not convergence also-
Correct.
It may even lead to exploding radiant also-
Exactly.
... if there's values.
Exactly, yes, yes, yes. Yeah.
Okay.
Sir, one more question. Um-
Yes, please.
... so when we are calculating loss, we are,
um, basically, uh, using a square,
uh, square of the loss, right? So that means we are, uh,
expressing the loss as a, uh, square of a particular variable
which is usually a, um, a parabola in...
if you look at... in a geometric way, right?
Hmm.
So that means, um,
loss expressed as
lo-... I mean, if we, if we are plotting the loss with respect to
any particular parameter, it will be a parabola and,
uh, we will be working with, uh, multiple parabolas and trying to
get a reasonable minimum across all these.
Exactly. Yeah, this is what, what happens, okay?
Uh, but, uh, here, in this case, I have chosen that loss
function because I had... I was, uh,
focusing, uh, from couple of classes on the
regression sort of problem where my ultimate output is some, some ve-...
uh, numeric value. Okay? But it may...
maybe the classification problem, and then you know that...
then in that such case, maybe squared error will not be in my ultimate
objective function or loss function. Uh, it will, it will change.
It may change to cross entropy or something like that.
Based on the problem statement, we will decide and then-
Okay.
... what, what will be our loss function. It will not be fixed for all the cases.
Yeah.
Okay, thanks.
Okay.
Excuse me, sir, I have one doubt.
Yes, sir.
Sir, uh, this, uh, D... dou L by dou theta
one, dou theta two, there will be multiple gradient descents,
right?
Uh, multiple gradient descent in the sense?
Like,
Gradient descent is an algorithm, yeah, where we are
having this update rule inside that.
We have multiple such, uh, gradients which we are calculating.
Correct, yeah.
Yes, sir. So the graph which you showed-
Uh-huh.
... where, uh, this is the sum-...
summation of all the, uh, thetas or
just one single theta, sir?
Only one single theta. Because we can't show the graph in more than three
dimension, right?
Yes, sir.
Uh, so that only... Oh, so here it is in two dimension and
next slide-
Hmm.
... in three dimension. More than three dimension-
... we just have to visualize it. It is, it is happening in the same way because my
equation is same, but I'm not able to-
Hmm. ... show you that plot because more than that we can't show any of the plotting.
Yes, sir, but one question is like dou L by dou theta one can be shown
separately?
Huh.
Dou L by dou theta two can be shown separately?
Thank you. So nine plots, it's, uh, like this, you can show nine different plots.
Yes, that is true. That is-
Okay, sir.
That is true.
Uh, just for understanding, sir.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you, sir.
And that is what is happening, if you want one dimension.
That is what-
Theta means all the parameters. So whatever W11, W12,
uh, it can be anything and for-
Uh-
... with respect to every parameter, it is happening in the same. Yeah.
Got it. Thanks.
Okay? Right. Let us move
ahead. Uh, I also have
some... and so on, I'll show you, maybe I'll...
after covering this gradient descent types.
So
we have three types of,
uh, gradient descent: the stochastic gradient descent, batch and
mini-batch. So,
uh, in the b-... I'll go... Batch gradient descent, what
happens, suppose you have... suppose you have, uh,
one, two, three, four, five, six data points,
okay? It's an entire corpus where you have six data points.
So the batch gradient descent, what happen,
you,
uh, you consider all the data points, so all the data points
are like a batch. Okay? So that is your corpus
and whole... all samples are creating one
batch. You process all the batch, means,
all six data points one by one. Okay?
Calculate the loss
separately for each of those, each of those data points,
then calculate the cumulative loss.
After calculating the cumulative loss, you call the gradient
descent. Okay? Now, let me repeat it.
So suppose there are six data point, as you can see here, in case of the batch, you
ca-... you process all the... say that there are six rows.
Imagine there are six rows. First row I'll send, do the forward
propagation, I'll get the prediction as Y hat, I'll calculate the
loss, that I'll say as loss one. Okay?
For the first data point. Then second data point, I'll pass.
I'll get the prediction, calculate the loss, I'll say loss two.
Then third data point, I'll pass. I'll get loss three, loss four, loss five, loss
six. Now for each data point, each row, I have got one, one
loss. Now what I will do is, I'll calculate the cumulative loss
or the mean squared error of loss, whatever you...
So for all the data point, you will do that one
together. So see, once I have done these six loss, I have calculated
cumulative loss. I have calculate...
I have not yet updated the parameter, that means that I have not done the back
propagation so far. Once I have the cumulative
loss, then I will start doing the back propagation. Okay?
And I'll change all those parameters, abs-...
all the parameters, and once... after changing the parameters, again
I'll, uh, I'll go for the next iteration where I'll again
feed all the six, uh, data, all the six samples, calculate
the loss again, cumulative loss, and again change the parameter, and this process
goes. So what is happening is, in the case of batch gradient descent,
updates happen after processing
entire samples from the corpus.Okay.
That is called batch gradient descent.
In the stochastic gradient descent, it's completely opposite.
So in the stochastic gradient descent, you
update the parameter, means you call the back propagation for
every sample. Suppose there are six sample, as you can see here,
okay? So you will take the sample, you will calculate the
prediction for it, calculate the loss.
Now, this much you are doing in the batch also, but after calculating the
loss, you are processing the second data point in the batch.
But in the stochastic gradient descent, what you will do, after one, first data
points, once we have calculated the loss, we'll, we'll update...
We'll call the back propagation, update all the parameters.
Okay? So, then we'll do it for second also, third also, fourth, fifth, six
also. So, in one iteration, six
times
update will happen for all the parameters in stochastic gradient
descent. But in the batch gradient descent, for one iteration only
one time update of the parameter will happen. Okay?
Now, this is the change in the batch gradient descent and stochastic gradient
descent. Then we have a mini-batch, which is in between batch and,
uh, stochastic, and which is proven to be the, uh,
trade-off between the faster and stable.
So usually use the mini-batch. So suppose you have, uh, six data
points, I will take the mini-batch of sample to...
So two, two data I will process, calculate the co-cumulative loss, update the
parameter. Again, next two sample, calculate.
So if there are two samples which we are taking together, that mean that for
six data point, for one iteration, three parameter, three times we will
do the parameter update.
So that is the change in this batch, uh, like, when, when, when
we see batch gradient descent, stochastic gradient descent and mini-batch gradient
descent. Okay? Now, the point is, how does it help,
okay, and where it helps? And how to understand that
which type of gradient descent we have to use when,
and how do we even enable that part?
That, okay, now I have to use a stochastic gradient descent, how to enable that
part? Okay. Or if I have to use batch gradient descent, how to enable
that part, right? So that is what we are going to see next and I will show you the
note, uh, what is that, demo also for that.
You will understand it clearly. So, uh, first of all, the batch
gradient descent. As I said, the batch gradient descent, what you do, you calculate
the loss, loss between X-I and Y-I, means one data, first
row.
Uh, so loss you calculate betw- for, uh, for the prediction and
the actual
and you do it for all the N data points.
So you calculate the mean square loss here.
So mean, this loss function is a square root, then it will be mean square loss.
So it's a mean loss what you are calculating here in the case of batch, because
you are first processing all the number of rows,
samples, en-entire data set. And then,
once after doing everything, you update the parameters, so you update this
theta
with respect to the loss. So if you see the points, it's very
stable updates, because you see all the data points
in your entire corpus
and loss coming from that. What is the cumulative loss
for entire data point? So you can have, you have a kind of
the rough knowledge of entire data set,
and then you do the update in the parameter.
So it is stable, it is kind of smooth, because you have seen everything
and then you are changing your parameters' value,
uh, in order to get the global minima.
But, uh, the computation is e-expensive for large data sets.
Suppose you have 100,000 rows in your data set.
So if you want to do one change in all set of
parameter, first of all, you have to process all those 100,000 rows
and then you will do
one change. Then you will go for the second iteration.
Again, you have to process all those 100,000 rows and then you have to do next
set of, uh, update in the parameter.
So it is smooth, but, uh,
uh,
it is smooth, stable, but it is computationally
expensive. It is computationally expensive. Okay?
So this is what happens in the case of the batch gradient descent.
Now, in the case of stochastic gradient descent, for every data sample, you
update, for update. So, uh, what
we say that the stochastic gradient descent is not smooth.
It's zigzag, like you can see here.
You are here and then you went here and then here, here,
here and so on. So you are trying to reach here to the global
minima but then because every... You have seen only one data point,
accordingly, you have changed all the parameters in your network.
And then you are processing second, uh, uh, row in your
corpus, calculate the loss and change all the parameter.
So it may happen for the first
row you are getting the loss this much,
okay? But the, for the second row, your loss will
significantly reduce because you have changed the parameter.
Then, uh, it may increase and may decrease. So it will not be smooth.
It will not be smooth. Okay? That is, that is the...
So SGD, stochastic gradient descent is not
smooth, but what it is saying that it is very fast.
The update is a very fast update it, it does, very fast
update it does. It has high variance, you can see that also, zigzag motion
can escape, uh, shallow minima. Here it is
escaping, it is, it is possible because it is very zigzag, it...
So it may, might happen that there is a minima and I must...
I will simply go to the other side of that one, because now I am
changing radically in my parameters.
So it is possible in this case. But the point is, uh,
it is going to be very fast and you will converge here fast.
You will converge here fast. Okay?
So it might be confusing that although...
Suppose I have 100,000 row. Suppose I have 100,000 row here in SGD
and 100,000, same 100,000 row here in batch gradient descent. Okay?
Now, say thatUh, uh, okay. Forget about one
lag row. It will, it will be difficult to, uh, compute.
So say that I have 100 rows, okay? For the simplicity, 100 rows in
my data set and say that 10 iteration I want to train.
When I say 10 iteration, 100 rows in my data set,
okay? So how many times I will change the
parameters? How many times? 10 times.
Suppose... Uh, whatever setup, um, 10 parameters suppose I have, then all
those 10 parameters I'll change 10 times in the batch gradient because I'm training
it for 10 iteration and parameter gets changed only
after that iteration, okay? Because we are processing entire
data set, all the 100 data ones, okay? And then changing the parameters.
So 10 times we are changing here the parameter. Same case if you take here.
Suppose we have 100 samples, 10 iteration I have to run, it
will go-
Processing an entire large data set all at once can cause memory
errors.
What is this? Sorry. So, uh,
um, so, yeah. So it will, it will do 10
into 100, 1000 times updates it, this will do, this SGD,
Stochastic Gradient Descent, because for every data point it is doing the updates
and then you have 100 data points and you are running f- it for 10
iteration. So in every iteration, 100 updates, 10 iteration,
1000 updates.
So obviously this will r- be running...
Uh, this will take more time obviously as compared to the grade,
uh, uh, Batch Gradient Descent but you, uh, but
the convergence in the case of SGD would be faster. Why?
Because after every sample you are updating the parameter,
after every sample, okay? So the update is happening
faster as compared to the
Batch Gradient Descent. So convergence in the case of SGD would be
faster, but time would be more. Time take, uh, time, uh,
time, uh, it will take more, okay? In terms of the time,
SGD may take more because hun- 1000 times updates it has to do.
Here you, uh, you will
do the updates only say that 10 times.
So that time would be less, but convergence here will be faster,
convergence here will be slower, okay?
So that is, that is how they are, uh, you have to understand this.
Then mini-batch is somewhere in between.
So you don't take whole data set to process or single data set to process
to update the parameter, but you make a batch of it.
So this is the best case you would say that if suppose I have 100
datas, uh, 100 data, uh, samples, I will take the batch of
10. I will take the batch of 10. Instead of taking one or 100, I'll
take now batch of 10. So it will be...
Uh, it is a trade-off between how soon you are converging or how
much, uh, uh, uh, h- uh, how much you can say
smoothness you are getting. Uh, so it's a, it's a, it's a kind of
trade-off. Fine? So if I
summarize, this is what it is. So Batch Gradient Descent, it process
all N data samples. Stochastic Gradient Descent, it sample, uh,
it process only one sample and mini-batch, it process M number
of sample out of N and then they do the update in
the parameters of the neural networks.
So if you take time to compute the Batch Gradient Descent, say 10,
10 epoch, Batch Gradient Descent is, uh, uh, time
per update... Sorry. Time per update is slowest because it has to process all
the N data points, then it has to do the update.
It's the fastest because only one data point, do the update, and then it is the
balanced one. Convergence, if, if you will see, Batch
Gradient Descent is smooth and stable, noisy zigzag but it is
fastest. It may converge fastest, okay?
So fast and stable. Now, one more thing about the
vectorization because now say that I have 100, uh, samples,
okay? So Batch Gradient Descent is highly vectorized in the
sense that you can use the dot product, dot product and, uh,
you can use the, th- uh, GPU, uh, quite well in the case of vectorizations and
doing calculations with that. SGD, very poor,
okay? Because one, one samples you are taking and also, and every time you are
updating that once, so vectorizations, uh, is very poor in the SGD.
Here it is again balanced. Fine? And it is
GPU-fri- friendly also. Why GPU-friendly?
Because your batch size would be equivalent to the RAM size but here because you
are processing entire data set, entire data set you can have millions of data, uh,
ji- millions of rows. That much maybe GPU will not support, so this
is GPU-friendly. Okay. I'll quickly show you the
demo and it will give you more insight about, okay, what is
happening. Okay. Instead of here, I'll go in
this here, here. So
I've already, uh, integrated it. It will be available for you to
practice. So what I am doing here is I'm just importing some of the
packages and here, uh, (clears throat) I'm
taking some random data samples, 500 data samples I'm
taking and it's equal to 500. Seed I'm fixing so that every data
samples I want to reproduce it sh- should not change when I'm
creating those samples manually, oh sorry, randomly.
And then there is a IQ column, CGPA column, okay, which is
there as an X, as an input, and then output will be my
LPA. So my IQ, I'm creating
randomly using rand integer value and those values,
IQ values are between 50 and 130 because that is the IQ
value I want to take. You can change this if you wish.
Okay, and then what is the size? Size is N cross
one, that means N rows, one column, means 500 values of the
IQ I'll generate. Similarly, I will do for CGPA
also. The range is between five and 10.
Okay. Uh, sorry. Uh, range is, uh, bit, uh, uh,
range is th- the empty N comma one, this is the
size, means 500 cross one, and the range will be, will be
between five and 10.So IQ and CGPA column, I'm generating by these two
line, my data I'm creating. And, uh, then I'm just
concatenating IQ and CGPA as X because these two are going
to be my input in my data. Then I am,
uh, creating my Y and Y
is, uh, this one, uh,
0.1 into IQ, 0.5 into CGPA
plus noise. I mean, this is not required, uh, if you want to take
directly as some value, LPA value, that also you can keep it, but here I have
kept in some range, okay? So here what I'm doing is X and Y I'm
creating input and label. X has two column, Y is the output, single
column. Fine? Then once we have done this one, then we are just
initializing some parameters. Same network which I have shown you, uh,
I'm, I'm trying to create this, this particular network.
Network, I'm not changing so that you will understand it, uh,
better. So network with two inputs, two hidden neurons and one
output, okay? Same thing, same setting I'm creating.
So I need all lo- all those nine parameters starting with W11,
W12, W21, W22, b1, b2, b3, v1, v2. All these
parameters are required and here I'm telling requires_grad is equal to
true because I'm going to use the auto grad.
I'm not going to write or calculate the gradient, uh, by our own.
We'll use the back propagate function for that one. Okay?
So that's why it requires_grad for all these parameter is equal to true.
We want to calculate the gradient with respect to each of these parameters.
That is what it meaning of it. Okay?
Now, forward pass, in the forward pass, I need X1,
X2, these two are my input. Fine? All rows and
the columns, uh, so this will select that one, and then I will
calculate first Z1. Z1 is
W1X1, W2X2, V1
and these are all available in my params,
parameters, okay? So, uh, I, I, I am
simply taking that, uh, because I'm receiving, uh, that in
the params, so, uh, I'll, I'll calculate then...
Once I calculate Z1, then I'll calculate the H1.
You can recall here, right? From Z1 to H1, Z2 to H2,
then V, Y. So that is what I'm doing Z1, H1, Z2, H2, Y
hat. You know that well, right? Once I have all these, then what
I will do is I will have to, uh, update the parameters.
That updation of the parameter I am doing ma- manually.
So far I have not shown you how to make it, how to use the auto, uh,
means, uh, uh, PyTorch module for this one, which we'll see later.
So update parameter, every parameter I have to update and learning rate I am
taking. Learning rate how much I have fixed?
Learning rate below, I guess somewhere I'll show you, learning rate is 10 to the
power minus four, same value which I have shown you there.
So that is what I have fixed here. Okay?
Uh, then, um, then, then just one by one I'm taking
every parameter, so parameter is equal to parameter minus
learning rate into gradient. Same thing.
And at last, I'm setting the parame- uh, gradient value to zero.
Okay? Gradient value to zero. Why?
Because every time when I go to the next iteration, I want my gradient to be zero.
Otherwise the gradient will accumulate. The...
Whatever will be the last gradient, it will use that one, which I don't
want. So this is just for the manual parameter update.
I'm using the for loop for that instead of writing one by one each.
Now, this is the training modes. Training.
So training what we have to do, the full batch, and this is for batch gradient
descent. Suppose we have 200 data, I'll use, uh...
How many data we have? We have 500 data samples, right?
And here I'm using it for 200 epochs.
When I say 200 epochs, how many times I'll do the update in these
parameters? 200 times, because after every
epoch, these will, this will update
and in every epoch, we are, uh, we are, uh, first
calculating the loss for entire data samples in the case of batch gradient
descent. So 200 epoch learning rate, okay?
And then we are also storing what is the loss history. Okay?
Now, they are all the simple, simple things you can calculate. What is the...
We are just calling the forward propagation, means this particular function.
It will calculate everything. Uh,
Z1, H1, Z2, H2 and it will return Y hat, Z1, Z2, H1, everything it
will return, uh, this forward function. Okay?
Then with the Y hat I'll calculate the loss, which is the mean squared error
then loss.backpropagate. Now this will calculate all the gradient for all the
parameters what I have, and then I'll call the update params,
means this particular function which will update my parameters.
Okay? All these things we have seen how to do this in the theory, and now this is
the code for that. And now I'm just calculating after each epoch, what is
my loss? What is my loss? So af- after every epoch, whatever is the
loss coming, that I'm appending in this loss history empty
list. That's all. Okay? Now this particular function is
for the batch gradient descent. Similarly, here I am doing
for stochastic gradient descent.
Same thing, same thing but stochastic means here the epochs are
same, these are all same. So epoch I will
run same time, only change would be now I will
only use one data for the update of the
parameter. Every time I will update the parameter but I'll process only one
data. So if suppose 200 epoch, in every epoch
I will do 500 updates. Why? Because my data size is 500.
So every sample I'll cal- do the forward propagation, calculate the loss, update
all the parameters. So 200 into 500, though that much time it will
run, obviously, it will take more time, you will see that. Okay?
It will take more time, SGD. The rest everything is same. Okay?
Rest everything is same, you can just, uh, look into that one.
Finally, we have the mini batch which will take the batch size
neither five, uh, batch size... Uh, here you see this,
there is one batch size is equal to 50 and, uh, here I
did not keep any batch size that means that the batch size by default,
um, i- it is-Okay, so-
Hello?
... one, one and here it is taking the complete, uh,
complete data. So that is the difference.
So here, extra parameter I'm keeping just to, uh, keep the
batch size, which is 50. That is the only change and rest, again, it will
work in th- this much epoch and for every batch,
mini-batch size, it will run the in- uh, inner loop and calculate the loss to
the back propagation and update the parameter and store the loss
history. Okay, now say that this, this also I
have calc- uh, before that,
uh, this one was... This one I have to calcula-...
This one I have to run and this one I have...
Now, what I want to show you that how much time it takes for each
of these cases. And for that one, this is the, uh, time which
I'm importing. This is a function timed for training for each of these
cases so I will calculate the start time, what is the end
time.
Okay? So that is what I'm calculating whenever I'll call this-
(clears throat)
... uh, uh, f- function now and function would be
this, whether a mini-batch, batch, or a stochastic gradient descent.
I'll calculate this time. Total time will be end minus start, so time
per epoch, that is also it- I- we are calculating.
So this cell is only for time calculating and here, we are actually calling the
function for those three: stochastic gradient descent, batch and
mini-batch. So we are just calling the, the
time, uh, uh, training this particular function,
okay, and train_full_batch, train_sgd and
train_minibatch. These are the inside parameter we are passing, and what are
these parameter? These parameters are nothing but the name of these functions.
Actually, we are calling these functions internally. Okay?
So yes, let us now... Uh, I'll show you. So if I... It will run.
So you see that full batch, full batch has taken
0.20 seconds. Time per epoch is
0.00. How many epoch we were running? 200 epoch we are running.
Here also 200 epoch, here also. So 200 epoch we are running,
time per epoch is 0.01 and total time it is taking is
0.20. So obviously, you can see that it is fast, okay?
It is faster. Faster in order to complete the
epoch, okay? Faster in... Not in order
to converge. Convergence means that
your loss is not changing, okay? Or, uh, so that is con-
convergence. So batch gradient descent is good to,
to, to complete the training for whatever number of epochs you have
fixed. Okay? Now, SGD you will see that it will take
the maximum time because after every data point, it is
updating all the parameter. 200 into
500. Those many times back propagation, the update of the
parameter is happening. It will take maximum time,
but see that it has taken 63 seconds.
Time per epoch is 0.31 and obviously mini-batch will be in between
because we have taken some batch size.
So now it is 1.38 seconds, right? So this is the result.
So it clearly says that SGD takes maximum time in order to
complete the training process, okay?
And then, uh, mini-batch and finally the full batch will take the minimum
time. But in order... Uh, if you see the
convergence, if you see the convergence, so this plot will... Th- this...
I just plotting the loss function because loss history we have stored in all
the cases. So this y-axis is a loss and, uh,
x-axis is my epoch and there are three curve.
One green for mini-batch, the SGD has this orange and this
blue is the full batch. Now, you will see
that, uh, the SGD
starts from here. SGD, stochastic gradient descent start from
here and it quickly converge after 25 epoch, means after
25 epoch, you will not see any change in this orange
line. Flat, that means that loss is not changing.
So after 25 epoch itself, it was converged.
If you talk about this full batch gradient des-...
This blue, it is starting here, going down, down, all these things you
will see, uh, but
I see here after around 65 epoch,
it has converged, okay? And if you talk about this
mini-batch, it i- it is still decreasing.
It is still decreasing even after 200 epoch.
It ha- it has not yet converged. I don't see the flat line in this loss, still
decreasing. So this is the chain. In terms of convergence,
SGD is faster. Why? Because it is taking more number of
updates, okay? But in terms of time for the
training, uh, full batch gradient descent is faster.
So this is what is the, uh, difference between this
batch, SGD and mini-batch gradient descent.
One more thing before you can ask me some questions, that usually what we
do, we prefer mini-batch usually, okay?
We don't prefer batch or SGD and, uh, we usually take
the, uh, m- mini-batch size in the power of two,
in the power of two. You, you will see that batch size if...
Suppose you have 100, uh, data points, you will take the batch size as, say
that 8, 16, 32, something like that, okay?
So power of two. Why? Because it, it optimizes your RAM
properly, right? Uh, the, uh... So it
optimizes the RAM properly and then, um, that is, that
is one reason that why mini-batch are, uh, taken in power of two.
But having said that, it is not always, uh, uh...
It is not all, uh, necessary to keep it in the power of two.
You can take the, uh, mini-batch size at 10 also.
So then it will go for 10, 10, 10, 10, 10, like...
Uh, you can take 50 also, you can take 40 also.
So when you take mini-batch size is equal to 40, so first
data set will be of 40 samples, second data set will
be of 40 samples, third data set will be of 20 samples.
40, 40, 20, that is how it will divide the data. Okay?
Now all these are some of the, uh, understanding, if you will have, you will be
able to train your network in a better
way. Okay? So now I'll take your questions first then I'll go move ahead.
Sir, I have a question.
Yeah, please.
So, let's, uh, now if we reduce the mini batch,
uh, size then-
Hmm.
... will the conversion, uh, time be lesser?
Uh, mini batch size, as you will reduce, it is approaching towards this
SGD.
Hmm.
Right? So obviously, maybe the convergence may happen a little
faster. Okay? That is what you went on, but, uh, you have to check that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I, I believe that it should happen because it is going towards SGD and SGD
behavior, you can see how it is.
Hmm. Yes.
Yeah.
Okay, sir. Got it. Thank you.
Okay.
Other questions? Is it clear?
Uh, sir.
Yeah. Yes, sir. One more question is, like, um, at, you know,
when first trying, we won't get the proper output.
So, like, I'm just comparing some practical things.
Yeah.
So, uh, once the model is trained, we get the outputs, we
feel that it, it doesn't comes through properly as we ...
Even in first semester, we s- saw some ANN.
Like, how its word is predicting.
Hmm.
So, uh, every time, again, we, uh, we updates our initial
parameters and then, again, we try.
So if we, uh, in that, in there, in thinking of full
aspects, so going with SGD, we'll get the, even the
training time is more, we get the things faster or
still we, uh, we, we can go ahead with mini batch or a full,
uh, full G- uh, GD?
I mean, you can take a call. It is not alwa- always necessary to
go ahead with mini batch. Okay?
Hmm.
Mini batch is, uh, recommended in such a case where dataset is
very big, say that you have millions of samples, which is available in your
dataset. Okay?
Hmm.
So in such cases, mini batch would be preferred,
right? But then, um, if your data sample is
small, you see that SGD-
Mm-hmm.
... is converging very fast, you can take a call to go ahead with the SGD.
It is not, uh, necessary to go ahead with the mini batch also.
Nowadays, like, we are in the LLM and generative models.
So, in this type that the data is huge, here which one is
more preferred, sir, mini batch or we're going with full row?
Um, usually, we... That's what I said.
In such a case-
Mm-hmm.
... where we have, uh, very high, um, dataset is
specific-
Okay. ... mini batch is preferred. Yeah.
Yes. Thank you, sir.
Okay.
Uh, yes, sir.
For SGD, as, um, you mentioned, sir, it is taking every data
part-
Hmm. ... for each of the iterations.
Mm-hmm.
So, the parameter, how it is updated, sir?
Each time the previous parameter is updated
or-
Uh-huh.
... parameter is stored somewhere and at last, it is
averaged out?
No, no. I suppose you have 500 samples, right?
Yeah.
So one sample, you will do the forward pass, you will calculate the loss
and you will update all the parameters.
So after every sample you have processed as a forward pass,
you will do the backward pass for it.
Okay.
So suppose 500 sample, 500 times you are doing the back
propagation in every iteration.
Yes, sir.
Or in every epoch, whatever you say. Okay?
So that is how it is being updated. So if you see here, when you are
updating the parameter, once I update this parameter by the same
rule, whatever we have there, that theta is equal to theta minus learning
rate into the partial derivative of that.
This is the same, same, uh, thing, only thing is here we are using the
grad or, uh, from the, uh, auto grad,
PyTorch. That's why it looks a little different, but it is the same equation.
After updating
wa- uh, all the parameter for, uh, for a particular
sample, we are making all the parameter value as zero in
place, uh, operation where, because I don't want that parameter
to get accumulated because after every sample, we are updating the parameter.
I don't want to take it as a last
up- uh, updated parameter value. It will go as zero.
In the next sample when you get a loss, again, you update it from,
uh, uh, uh, gradient becomes zero.
Para- not para- uh, parameter, sorry. The gradient becomes zero.
I don't want my gradient to be a- uh, to get accumulated.
Parameters will be intact. Yeah.
Yes, sir.
Yes,
sir. So this happen for every epoch actually?
Uh, uh, every epoch, every data point.
Every data point.
Uh, every da- in SGD.
Yes, I have seen.
Suppose 500 data point, means 500 times update will
happen for every epoch.
And suppose-
Mm-hmm.
... you have fixed the 200 epochs, so 200 into 500.
Those many, those many updates will happen in SGD.
But, but in batch, only 500 update will happen and
in mini-
Yes,
sir. ... batch, you divide it or your data points by that, uh, so accordingly, the
update will happen. Yeah.
Yeah. Got it, sir. Thank you, sir.
Okay.
All right?
Yes, sir.
Uh, then, uh, this much we have covered.
Now let me see. Uh, we have few, uh,
uh... I'll just quickly cover this vanishing gradient problem.
You will be able to understand now what is this vanishing gradient problem.
Okay. So, uh, as it- uh, as it
says, gradient. Gradient, all of us understand, right?
In the back propagation, gradient
decides, uh, uh, that, uh, your, uh,
uh, your... in which direction you have to go.
In the sense, whether you have to increase the value of the
parameter or you have to decrease because
theta is equal to theta minus gradient. That is what is.
So if the gradient is positive, you will decrease from the
theta. If gradient is negative then you will increase into theta.
So that gradient decide that what will be the next theta, what will be the
next update in the theta. That is the gradient.
And gradient, uh, uh, says that, okay, if you change that
theta with this amount, what will be the change in the
loss? But the problem with the gradient is that it may
vanish.Okay, it may vanish. Vanish when I
say gradient is, uh, anyway we want to keep the gradient
value, uh, small. Uh, I don't want to keep very high or very
low. So if the gradient is very low
then there is a problem, something called as vanishing gradient problem which may
occur in the artificial neural network.
So what is the vanishing gradient problem?
During the back propagation, gradients are computed layer by layer.
That we have already seen, right? Using the chain rule.
If the multiplicative factors are less than one, that means the
gradient, whatever gradient which is coming is less than
one, that product would be,
uh, their, uh, their product across many layer can shrink exponentially
towards zero
and result would be various small gradients for early layers
and then weights hardly update, training will not
happen. So what is the meaning of all these things?
And for that one, let me just, uh, take one
example.
So we are calculating the gradient, right, and say that the gradient value is
very small like 0.1, just for the example.
Gradient will come something but I am saying that it is very small.
Small when I say, when it is less than one. Okay?
And every time when I calculate the gradient it is very small.
Now you know that the, whenever you are calculating the gradient
with respect to any parameter, you go with the chain rule.
In the chain rule what you do, you multiply multiple gradients like
this. So when you will multiply the multiple gradients
like this and their values are very small like this suppose,
then you will end up with
very small value, like zero point, the val- value which is
0.001, right, 00. You can say that one.
So now see that this gra- uh, the, when you multiply these small value,
you will get even smaller values. Okay?
Now, uh, imagine that you have 10 layers.
10 layer, hidden layer. When you started at the output layer, gradient was
0.1, then the next again 0.1, next 0.1.
You are going back to the input layer, means 10 times you are adding this.
Means that 1 into 10 to the power of minus 10 you have already reached,
which is very small, which is nothing but zero, if you will see that.
Now, when it becomes zero, then what will happen?
That you, uh, that I guess all of you know quite well.
I just want to
show you that, uh, uh, wait
here. Uh, not here. Let me go back a little bit.
Yeah. Say that this, this particular part. Now say that this is my gradient.
Theta is equal to theta minus, um, learning rate into
gradient. Now see that this whole part is
very small or zero. This whole term becomes zero.
If this whole term becomes zero, theta is equal to theta, means there is no change
in the parameters. So from whatever layer onwards
if theta
remains theta, that means that whatever weight you have from that layer
and the previous layer, there is no change in the weights.
Next time when you are feeding the input, there is no change in those weight, those
weights were not updated and hence you will not see the change in the
ultimate loss. Or very, uh, the, the loss is
not reducing because initial layer, initial layer weights are
not being updated because this is the problem.
If this, uh, part becomes zero, this gradient becomes zero,
then your para-parameter will not change. Okay?
That is what we have seen. So vanishing gradient problem is
that itself. It says that what happens in case of the ANN
when you have multiple hidden layers like that and suppose you
have used some activation function like sigmoid.
Now sigmoid you know that how does it behave?
So here, a1,
uh, is a sigmoid of ƒ1. Say that whatever weight is sum plus bias you
will get, you will pass it through the sigmoid.
Now sigmoid has a tendency to squash your value
in the range of zero to one. Now zero to one is like 0.1, 0.2,
0.3, something like that, right? Suppose you have here also 0.1, here also
0.1, 0.1, 0.1 and all these are gradient, so all of
these you are going to multiply in order to calculate the gradient with respect to
w1 and hence here you will feel that gradient is
becoming almost zero and w1 weight is not changing.
If w1 weight is not changing, this, this, this layer is remain
same, you will not see much change here also in the param- Maybe this
layer weight we will change, this will change slightly.
It may not change, it will be almost zero so you will not see much change in
the y hat and as well as the loss also.
That means that that, uh, parameter is not
updated, parameter is not being updated if the vanishing gradient problem will
come into it at all, and that is not good at all, uh, it's not good for the
network. So I have,
uh... Okay, let me stop here maybe because 9:15
already. I don't want to go... I have one example.
I'll upload this slide, you can go ahead and in the next class I will show you this
vanishing gradient problem with this examples, okay?
And, uh, you will understand it better and then I am left with that, okay, how
to address this vanishing gradient problem.
So there are certain ways for addressing this gradient vanishing
problem that also we'll discuss, like reducing the model complexity.
Suppose 10 layers are there, you reduce to two layers but that may not help always
when data is unstructured. You can use the activation function
like ReLU, you can initialize the weight, uh, properly,
you can use batch normalization or res- residual connections.
We'll see, we'll see all these things. Yeah.
Uh, excuse me sir, the code will be available later?
Everything is, everything is integrated in this, uh, slide.
Slide will be available. You can click and you can get the code.
Okay, thank you sir.
Si- just to, last question sir. Uh, in even
the vanishing or in the conversions the graph will come straight line
sir?
Right? If
Uh, the graph, uh, here suppose this is the case,
what will happen-
Yeah.
...vanishing gradients means for a particular parameter, for a particular
parameter your slope will be almost like this-The first
thing that I
would
like to do is to look at
data
and
see if there are
any
problems
with the
data.
The second
thing, which is
very
important for me, is to
make sure that we have
a good understanding
of what's
going
on
in the
data. So it's not
just about the
data
but also how you can use it.
And then
finally, I
think
this is where I'm
most interested
in looking at the data. It's
really
interesting because when you're
dealing with data, you need to be able
understand what's happening within your data.
You
know, as far as
I've been doing this, I don't want to go
back into the past. But I'd love to get some insight from people
who are working with
data.
Because
they'll
tell us things that aren't necessarily true or even
possible. They might say something that seems plausible,
actually isn't. That's why I find it
so
interesting.